thousands of young people crammed into
this convention center in the capital
for an unusual Festival photo boots
allowed visitors to take pictures with
presidential candidates and sample
ballot sheets for firsttime voters to
practice before election
day I hope this will educate me about
what to do when I vote the election
Festival was organized by a group called
bjac mimili which means Choose Wisely
they said it was a rare chance for young
voters to discuss politics with
candidates I think we should look at an
election like we're we're going to hire
somebody to do a job for us the
independent organization has also
created an online platform detailing the
campaign Promises of each of the
candidates as well as past achievements
and
controversies of the more than 200
million Indonesians registered to vote
more than 63 million are aged between 17
and 30 so tailoring their campaigns to
appeal to young people is a key priority
for each of the
candidates the campaign for front runner
pror subbiano has made the most obvious
attempts to appeal to young voters
making use of celebrity endorsements and
cute caricatures to soften the image of
the former General and current defense
minister polling indicates those efforts
are working now the campaign that's
performing best among younger voters
among these under 30 voters is the proo
run ticket uh they reached a majority
among people under 25 I think back in
before
December you groups say this election
represents a chance to bring issues such
as environmental concerns employment and
education into Focus even though young
people have little influence when it
comes to policymaking PowerUp is a
coalition of youth organizations all
calling for stronger commitments from
every candidate to address climate
change ition shows that young people
actually have different concerns like
human rights indigenous peoples and the
economy but we are all aligned on the
climate issue they say it's an historic
opportunity and are calling on young
people to recognize their power in
shaping Indonesia's future Jessica
Washington Al jazer
jakata make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer